(upbeat music)
- Nice grip, Shania!
You're gettin' strong.
Your forearms are good.
- (gasp) Shania Twain.
- Since Season One, Abbi,
who's a trainer at the gym,
she's been lying that
she trains Shania Twain.
Which came about just because
train and Twain sound similar.
So it was kinda just, like,
a stream of consciousness,
"I'm training Shania Twain."
And, as fate would have it,
today we have Shania
Twain as a guest.
- Man, I feel like a smoothie.
- She was so funny.
She was so down to play
with herself as an icon.
She, like, riffs this song-
- ♪ When there's a spark,
you've got to ride it
- (vocalizes guitar sound)
- ♪ When there's a spark,
you've gotta ride it
Oh, when you're in
love, don't hide it
Ooh!
(bleep) I'm good!
- We were singing that-
Like, the crew was singing that.
- Such an honor, she was so
fun, and sweet, and funny.
- Honestly, I wanna go
home and watch Friends.
- I love Friends
- I'm such a Chandler.
- I'm such a Ross.
/ - Total Rachel.
- A little Gunther, also.
- Oh, I'm a little bit Phoebe.
- In terms of Abbi
and Trey's dynamic,
we never saw it coming.
It's something that
kinda just happened.
- Say it, Trey.
Just say it once.
- Bazinga.
He's a fitness guy, and she's,
like, a quirky artist girl,
and he doesn't really get her.
But Trey really
cares about Abby,
and has always really liked her.
At some point, we realized,
in just shooting a scene,
Trey and Abbi have chemistry.
Something's goin' on.
And then Ilana was, like,
"Yes, this is happening."
And, so, it kinda
snowballed from there.
People who watch the show
seem to be really into it,
and, like, shift
to Abbi and Trey,
and so, it was really almost
a surprise to all of us.
- We really like the idea
that the Broad City world
keeps living, even when
we're not watching it.
Stuff happened between Abbi and
Trey, and, like, fell apart.
- Abbi just didn't handle
it right at the end,
and Trey and the gym didn't
didn't have any closure.
- We wanted to give Trey
a goodbye, a farewell.
- Let me train her
with you, okay?
I could be your Goose.
- Do not bring up
Top Gun right now.
- It felt like a different
way of storytelling;
it was, like, backtracking
of dealing with
the end of a hookup.
Just felt like a really fun way
of finishing off their story.
Okay ... Shania?
Can you call 9-1-1?
- Yeah.
His dick is definitely broken.
(upbeat music)